hitting rock bottom there's hardly the
space to list all the successful people
who have hit rock bottom
JK Rowling finds herself seven years
after college with a failed marriage no
job single parent kid she can barely
feed and approaching homelessness
Hemingway at 19 is serving as an
ambulance driver in World War one
convinced like many young men of his own
invincibility a mortar round than a
six-month hospital stay shattered both
his legs and at illusion
in Greek mythology characters often
experience calabasas or a going down
they're forced to retreat the experience
of depression or in some case they
literally descend into the underworld
when they emerge it's with heightened
knowledge and understanding we surround
ourselves with BS with distractions with
lies about what makes us happy and
what's important we become people we
shouldn't become and engage in
destructive awful behaviors this
unhealthy and Eagle derived state
hardens and becomes almost permanent
until Calabasas forces us to face it
hard things are broken by hard things
the bigger the ego the harder the fall
in fact many significant life changes
come from moments in which we are
thoroughly demolished in which
everything we thought we knew about the
world is rendered false whatever the
cause they can be catalyst for change we
were petrified to make good or bad the
choice is ours pick a time in your life
or perhaps is a moment you're
experiencing now a boss is a viscera and
critique of you in front of the entire
staff that sit down with the person you
love the Google Alert that delivered the
article you'd hoped would never be
written the call from the creditor the
news that threw you back in your chair
speechless and dumbfounded it was in
those moments when the break exposes
something unseen before that you were
forced to make eye contact with a thing
called truth no longer could you hire to
pretend we might have been delusional to
head off and acknowledge our own flaws
such a moment raises many questions how
do we make sense of this how do I move
onward and upward is this the bottom or
is there more to come
someone told me my problem so how do I
fix them how do I let this happen how
can it never happen again the world
breaks everyone and afterward many are
strong at the broken places but those
that will not break it kills the world
can show you the truth but no one can
force you to accept it Vince Lombardi
said this once a team like men must be
brought to its knees before it can rise
again
so yes hitting bottom is as brutal as it
sounds but the feeling after is one of
the most powerful perspectives in the
world if you shut up truth and bury it
on the ground it will but grow and
gather to itself such explosive power
that the day it bursts through it will
blow up everything in its way emile zola